christian bale looks nearly  unrecognizable  pulling off another drastic weight  transformation for his latest role  this time the actor is packing on the  pounds as he prepares to play dick  cheney in the upcoming biopic back seat  the 43 year old star attended the  telluride film festival in colorado over  the weekend and on sunday bell stepped  out in a casual ensemble displaying a  much fuller figure he even dyed his  eyebrows blonde to channel the former  vice president  well this body transformation isn't the  first for the oscar-winning  actor i look okay if you were any  thinner you wouldn't exist  we've seen bell lose over 60 pounds for  his role in 2004's the machinist i don't  think it was something that i would wish  to do again it ain't great for your  health and bulk up for his iconic role  as the dark knight in 2005's batman  begins  i'm batman  [Music]